what happened exactly to Lord Sugar what
was he talking about people fraudsters
scanning on a B&B we talking about his
properties being used well I tell what
happened absolutely nothing really
happened so basically no one used Lord
Shiva's house no one stayed at Lord
Sugar's house nothing happens all they
did was someone put up a phony advert on
everybody and they scraped the station's
websites and happened to use a picture
of Lord Sugar's house on the inside so
people are kind of freaking out you know
my gosh lordship is that there's Airbnb
scammers does that mean the rent to rent
using a servant accommodation Airbnb is
a scam if Lord Sugar said it did someone
do it to little sugar no no the scam
that happened is completely nothing like
what a legitimate read to rent rent to
serviced accommodation properties are
what happened is someone advertised the
property that didn't exist it didn't
exist but it won't available for rent
advertised it for rent and it didn't
exist listen that is not only is he
completely illegal not only is it fraud
but also you're never going to make
money doing that because what happens is
air baby hold on to your money and then
when the person comes and then when the
person checks out everything release the
funds so if you miss sell a property and
it doesn't exist and then the guests
come and you waste their time and what's
gonna happen is Airbnb r just gonna give
a refund to the guests and you as the
amazing fraudsters are going to fraud
nobody have anything apart from wasting
people's time I think what sugar was
just frustrated because his pictures of
his property got used in this scam just
for the record to be really clear but no
one was inside Lord Sugar's house Lord
Sugar's not talking about wait to
serviced accommodation there's nothing
wrong with renting out your property
legitimately on Airbnb there's nothing
wrong with renting out someone else's
house as long as you do properly and
then managing that property and renting
it out on Airbnb as long as you do leave
here with the correct contracts the
correct assurances that is not what
Little Joe was talking about so I hope
that clears things up a little bit and
whatever you're doing I wish you a
wonderful day
oh and I almost forgot if you want to
watch me doing a winter and deal
properly then just watch this video
right here if you want to watch and hear
a story of
and Cheryl who are making 14,000 pounds
per month doing rent to serviced
accommodation here the story right here
and if you'd like to just spend a couple
of days learning how you can do the same
at a live training program then click on
the link more here either way please do
subscribe and I look forward to seeing
you on the next video